copies of the start so very simple like
I like that bit right and I multiply
those by each other we transition to one
out for both because get a lot more
difficult right for a good reason like
as you start to see what I'd fall is is
packed with insights and it's a much
more powerful way to describe the of it
but therefore it kind of you know you
have to have all the do streak stuff
like sifting around in the background
and it doesn't hold your hand through it
okay so this is harder this is where
complex numbers we're kind of at the arm
you guys know we're kind of the
inflection point where it's like just
really ramping up okay but um it's worth
it so quality hats now let's remember if
I've got to complex on this like so the
last thing we're spending most of our
time on was multiplication right and in
one art form what multiplication looks
like so if this is that one this is it
to us just reverse the product is n1 and
n2 is okay what do we do with the moduli
we multiply the months right so our one
our twos gonna be hanging out in front
that's the modulus what do we do with
the argument in Diego's right we
multiply boards we add right so I get
cos of alpha yep and then you've got
your plus I sine okay so as you see we
multiply once we add arcs now that
pushes other things a little bit because
you might remember we defined public
suppers it's kind of like translation
right and then when you add complex
numbers you're shifting around just
horizontally or vertically but when you
multiply we said rotation is happening
yes but is nothing but when you look at
this if you think about this carefully
you realize we've already seen examples
that demonstrate this that more than
just rotation is happening right
rotation is just about like going round
and round and round so that is to do
with the angle right that's what
rotation is but something is happening
here as well right the magnitude the
size of the complex number is also
changing okay so there's more than just
rotation the way that I remember it is
that when you multiply
oh thanks you don't really rotate don't
just think about it in terms of rotation
but you do two things come in usually
things number one you multiply these
mods which geometrically means for
instance if I had another like saying
let's take it one let's take a simple
example on I okay so you know where that
is it's on the purely imaginary axis
okay now if I multiply that by another
simple complex of my life saying - right
no rotation is happening okay why is the
rotation happening with a x - because
you know because what's the argument
that I add what's the argument of -
where is to choose right there are the
real axis right well the positive real
axis I should say since I'll give it a
zero now there's the rotation thing
happening or as it is not happy okay but
what else happens to it well obviously
yeah that one's a - is 2i right so there
was i before right what's your bottom
line by - you've got to eye down and
it's twice as far away beyond the
modulus just doubled okay so the way I
remember it
there's just there's just so much
awesome alliteration that happens in
combine something to do oh not only are
you retaining your scaling
right you're scaling and when you think
about rotation you're your old tiny
simple word for rotation is spinning
right you're turning something about you
spinner so multiplying is not just
rotation it's more than rotation I
remember as its scaling and it's fitting
that's what multiplication means now we
established this we demonstrated through
the trig identities okay but I want to
have a look at some of the implications
on this that come out a little bit more
okay um you can also do this in Reverse
do you notice that like I'm thinking of
this from the point of view of okay I
know what my complex numbers are tell me
how to combine them okay I can go in
reverse and I can say if I've got
something which is clearly a product
they already combined
can I come backwards right so for
instance let's think about these things
one at a time right let's think about
the modulus of Z 2 right if I already
have the product worked out for me okay
then based on the fact that I multiply
moduli by a multiplies then the modulus
of this is clearly the modulus of this
this just by itself right so I'm sort of
going in Reverse now okay this is like I
know the numbers now I'm getting the
product this is if you know the product
can you can you glean some insight from
it by try to go and reverse try to
reverse a GDP okay that's both of my
boys what about the arguments if x is
gives me this relationship then if I
have this and I know that this is a
product right what could I say about the
argument of the product okay so I've got
this argument that's one of them right
there's the first angles plus the other
one right okay does that make sense now
there are so there are so special cases
for these what we call identities that
do not change either the modulus or the
hybrid so we had a look at what just a
second ago okay let's have a look at
this one
see you remember I felt applied by two
multiplied by two right so what happened
to the argument in this case from the
original number to the product and the
answer is the argument didn't change why
didn't the argument change it's because
the argument I was adding was zero does
that make sense okay so here's my arm is
my particular example if I'm let's
introduce a let's call it
if the argument of Samba is zero right
sorry that's the robot if the island of
Omega zero then the argument of anything
x over Y R will be unchanged do you see
that right because the argument of
adding will be R zero right that's right
will be will be zero so therefore this
is just unchanged just like it was here
the hot in a second what does it mean
what kinds of numbers there's a whole
family of numbers that has an argument
on zero
where are they my twos was not real it's
the real numbers but more specifically
it's not just the real numbers they're
only so it's got to be the positive ones
right because if I speak about my
complex plane here right I start
measuring from the positive real axis
these numbers over here like minus 1
minus 2 minus 3 they are also real
they're real numbers but they argued
it's non zero what is the argument over
there on PI radians right so therefore
that would quite significantly change so
that's what I've got here if the angular
momentum is zero in other words if Omega
is a positive real number then when you
multiply some other complex of light
yeah sure but I was I was picking up off
this again okay now I'm gonna think
about this example now in Reverse okay
let's think about to multiply by I okay
which is like one isn't that the same
thing well I want to think about now
what numbers do I multiply by that leave
my modulus unchanged do you notice the
modulus of this number of this number of
same right 2 + 2 I
he's to and he is to either the same
list as the modulus as I've changed
so how would you say this right what
particular kind of moments yeah okay so
if now the particular example I've
chosen is I can you think of another
number I could multiply by that would
not change the modulus of the number 9
multiplied by one would work 2 times 1
will still be to give me another one
another double-check the x and it
wouldn't change their motives yeah I've
got one so far I negative one come on
heavily keep it up maybe mama do it
right in fact because I am multiplying
too much like here right anything with a
bunch of us all one right anything with
a bunch of this one if you multiply that
then the modulus would change because
you're multiplied by one so I'm gonna
say if the modulus of Omega is equal to
one right then the modulus of any number
multiplied by Omega it would change okay
let me read that again okay so you know
you don't you try to see like what it's
like getting pretty notation dense right
if you've got a number and its modulus
is one that's how far away it is from
the other thing then if you multiply
some other complex number by that number
that's one away right it won't change
your modulus right of the module server
Zenobia will still be there